pédaler le long de 200 ans d'histoire du
berry une première pour nathalie et jean
marc en vacances dans le cher c'est
cycliste breton ne regrette pas d'avoir
pris leur vélo la piste est goudronnée
on peut faire du vélo librement
tranquillement dans un cadre bucolique
c'est fantastique quoi on vient de
bretagne côté de rennes et on fait
souvent le long délai du canal de l'île
et errance ou ce pareil c'est très
agréable sauf que c'est pas bitumée donc
ça va beaucoup moins bien qu'ici une
première piste cyclable de 6km flambant
neuf le long de ce canal de 260
kilomètres de quoi attirer les touristes
comme dans ce camping
j'ai quelqu'un qui vient vers le 18
qu'il a réservé ici comme chaque été
touristes belges et hollandais ont pris
leurs quartiers avec la nouvelle piste
la direction va revoir son offre pour
anticiper l'augmentation des
cyclotouristes vers le 15 septembre de
cette année vont être installés deux
petites cabanes de type bivouac donc
avec abri à vélos et couchages dont la
petite cabane en bois pour les touristes
à vélo qui vont souhaiter faire des
arrêts d'une soirée et voire de quelques
heures les cyclistes une aubaine à
quelques kilomètres de là
ludovic et caroline ont repris ce
restaurant en octobre dernier séduit par
le projet cyclotouristique ces nantais
se sont déjà adaptés à leur clientèle où
on a décidé d'ouvrir cette affaire pour
l'été du 1er avril au 30 septembre tous
les jours de la semaine sauf le dimanche
soit lundi soir mais en faisant aussi
les arrêts vélo randonneurs pour tous
les après midi en faisant de la limonade
des petits sandwichs d'ici la fin de
l'année ce chemin pierre sera lui aussi
entièrement goudronnée pour rejoindre à
6km la commune d'aînés le vieil au total
190 km de pistes cyclables seront
aménagés d'ici 2025
un projet qui coûte 21 millions d'euros
financés par le département la région et
des fonds européens